أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
لكن كان من الجميل أن يكون لدينا الكثير من
الأشخاص من الآخرين يأتون ويعملون
معنا، نحن نقوم الآن
بتوثيق كبير عن مدينة حلب
للسماح بمستقبل إعادة الإعمار
لأن هذا قد تم تدميره وليس لديك أي
صورة عنه ولا توجد خطة لا
يمكنك إعادة بنائه، لذا جمالنا الآن هو
أن نقول نحن كمؤرخين أننا نجمع كل
المواد معًا حتى يتمكن الآخرون من البدء في
إعادة الإعمار وهذا  تم
تدميره كما ترى، لا يزال هناك
ثقوب الرصاص من الحرب العالمية الثانية، لقد
ولدت بعد 20 عامًا من الحرب العالمية الثانية،
ولم أر
أطلالًا بدأ الناس في إعادة البناء
بالطبع، الأمر بالنسبة لسوريا أكثر صعوبة
من ألمانيا ولكن يمكن
إعادة بناء كل شيء  لذا فهي ليست نهاية التاريخ
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
مدينة [موسيقى] [موسيقى] أجنبية
وأنا أحب أه أيضًا أهل حلب الآخرين
ولكن الأمر هو أن لله
أهمية بيئية ومعمارية أكثر أهمية بكثير من
العديد من المدن  في المنطقة ربما كما
يمكنك القول أن إسطنبول
هي تلك الأهمية في منطقة
دمشق أيضًا، ومن المهم بالطبع أن
أرى أنها واحدة من
الهيكل التجاري وهي واحدة من
أهم المدن في جميع أنحاء العالم ومن
المحزن جدًا رؤيتها بالطبع  هذا القدر منه
دمر
[موسيقى]